it's a body of water that was so
polluted for so long it was often
referred to as america's forgotten river
but thanks to a slow and steady cleanup
effort the anacostia river has improved
to the point where aquatic life can
actually be seen swimming in its waters
again this is the clearest i've ever
seen the water down here
and now the continued improvement of the
washington dc river rests with the
freshwater mussel
the part clam part snail-like shellfish
it's creating water marine biologists
from the anacostia watershed society
have released over 26 000 native mussels
into the river they act as sort of a
natural vacuum cleaner to cleanse the
water muscles are our
[Music]
filter filter feeders so they help clean
the water
one muscle of the size of the muscles
we're collecting today can filter
between 10 to 20 gallons of water a day
so when you add up the numbers in a year
that's a lot of water that they can
filter
the mussels filter the equivalent of 106
olympic-sized swimming pools of water
every year this is what they filtered in
less than two hours but propagating
mussels and reintroducing them to the
river has had a dual impact clean the
river and help keep them from going
extinct in the united states
we need to work to conserve muscles
because greater than 70 percent of them
are listed as endangered threatened or
are just of like conservation concern
and there's like 300 species of
freshwater mussel in the united states
so when you think of like 70 percent of
that 300 species
they are at great risk and they help
in many ways these mussels are coming
home because before this river got so
polluted it killed most of them off
there are more than eight different
types of mussel species that lived here
it was in 2018 biologists started
reintroducing them in an experimental
project and it appears to be working for
a once polluted river now on its way
back to being healthy thanks in large
part to a most unlikely shellfish
gabriel lozando al jazeera washington